labour is using the alternative vote  system which means voters rank the  candidates in order of preference rather  than choosing just one in the first  round everyone's first preferences are  counted if no candidate wins more than  fifty percent of the vote the person  with the fewest is eliminated and their  ballots are redistributed using the  voters second choice if there's still no  winner with more than fifty percent of  the vote the process happens again the  candidate with the fewest votes is  eliminated and their next preference  votes are counted until someone has more  than half of the votes and they've won